Vezetői útmutató.
A szeretet ne legyen képmutató.
Iszonyodjatok a gonosztól,
ragaszkodjatok a jóhoz. A
testvérszeretetben legyetek egymás irány
gyengédek, a tiszteletadásban egymást
megelőzők.
Pál rómaiakhoz írt levele 12. fejezet
9-10-es vers.
Beidenbow Companies.
Spirituális alapok.
A Benbow út.
A legjobb vezetők nemcsak eredményesen
vezetnek, hanem hosszan és átgondoltan
reflektálnak vezetői gyakorlatukra, hogy
megfogalmazzák azokat az alapelveket,
amelyek vezérlik őket. Akár az üzleti
világban, akár civil vagy egyházi
szolgálatban dolgoznak, a jó vezetők
könnyedén meg tudják határozni döntéseik
és tetteik indokait. Épp, hogy
természetesen, mint ahogy a lakcímüket
mondanák el. Bill Hbels. A Bidenbo
Companiesnál alkalmazott kapcsolatalapú
vezetési stílusunk eltér a legtöbb
szervezetétől. A különbségek közül
néhány szinte észrevétlen, míg mások
radikálisabbak, de mindegyik hozzájárul
a kultúránkhoz és a sikereinkhez.
Néhány különbség az alapítóink által
belénk plántált alapelvekből ered, míg
mások az idők során organikusan
fejlődtek ki. Sokáig azt hittük, hogy
ezek az elvek törzsi tudásnak
tekinthetők, amelyeket szavakkal nem
lehet átadni, csak a vezetői
csapatunkban dolgozva, másokat
megfigyelve és a csapatok szolgálatán
keresztül lehet elsajátítani. Bár ez
bizonyos elemekre igaz, kiderült, hogy
az ideológiánk jelentős részét mégis meg
lehet fogalmazni. Ezeknek a
koncepcióknak a többsége már régóta
irányadó a vállalatunknál, de csak nem
rég fogalmazták meg hivatalosan.
Valójában ez az egész könyv a tapasztalt
vezetőink ötletbörzéjével indult,
amelynek keretében az igazgatótanács
tagjait is megkérdeztük két dologról.
Mik azok az alapelvek, amelyek
megkülönböztetik a vezetési stílusunkat
az üzleti életben? Milyen alapfogalmakat
kell feltétlenül megértenie egy új
vezetőnek ahhoz, hogy sikeres legyen a
szervezetünkben?
A legfontosabb gondolatokat, amelyek
felmerültek, ebben a könyvben, foglaltuk
össze, és később frissítjük ezeket,
ahogyan Isten fokozatosan finomítja és
érleli a látásmódunkat. Nehéz volt
ezeket a fogalmakat pontosan
meghatározni és körülírni, de reméljük,
hogy ez az erőfeszítés segít
megteremteni a tisztánást és az
összhangot egyre növekvő
szervezetünkben. Lehetővé teszi, hogy a
jövővezetői mélyebben megértsék
szervezetünk működését és belső
értékeit. Minden egyes témánál
igyekeztünk a legrövideben bemutatni az
alapelvet, akár egy másik szerző
írásából vett részlet átdolgozásával és
kiegészítésével, akár teljesen új szöveg
megírásával. Minden egyes fogalmat egy
cikkbe sűrítettünk, amely tömören
bemutatja az adott alapelvet. Hogyan
használjuk ezt a könyvet? Ez a könyv nem
arra készült, hogy együtt ő helyünkben
elolvassuk. Minden cikkben sűrűn
fordulnak elő igazságok és fontos
pontok. A legjobb, ha naponta egy cikket
olvasunk el, hogy elgondolkodhassunk
azon, hogyan alkalmazhatjuk ezeket a
napi munkánkban és vezetési
gyakorlatunkban. Ezt a könyvet soha nem
szabad egy új vezetőnek önálló olvasásra
odaadni. Az új vezetőknek a vezetőjükkel
együtt kell átnézniük az egyes cikkeket,
és ezek a beszélgetések további kontext
és gyakorlati példákat adnak az
alkalmazásra. Ezeken a beszélgetéseken
keresztül az ismertetett fogalmak
megelevenednek, és az új vezetők
világosabb képet kapnak. Arról a
vezetési stílusról, amelyhez
elköteleződtek. Vezetői fejlődésünk
érdekében az egyik legnagyobb hatású
tettünk az volt, hogy megírtuk ezt az
útmutatót. Ez arra késztetett minket,
hogy alaposan átgondoljuk, mik is az
alapelveink, és kiválogassuk, melyek
azok, amelyek valóban alapvetően
fontosak. Mi alatt számtalan órát
töltöttünk azzal, hogy a fogalmakat
kifejtsük, mélyen megismertük őket.
Szívünkbe vésődtek és részünkké váltak.
Mire az első verzió megjelent, már
könnyen felismertük azokat a
pillanatokat, amikor ezek az alapelvek
érvényesültek, és azokat is, amikor nem.
Ez katalizátorként szolgált saját
vezetői fejlődésünkhöz.
Hisszük, hogy számodra is hasznos lesz,
ha olvasás közben időről időre megállsz,
elgondolkodsz, és kéred Istent, hogy
mutassa meg, hogyan alkalmazhatod jól
ezeket az alapelveket. Az erő nem az
elvek megtanulásában rejlik, hanem azok
alkalmazásában.
A tudás cselekvés nélkül szakadékod hoz
létre aközött, amit tudsz, és amit
ténylegesen teszel. A végső cél nem az
ismeretszerzés, hanem az alkalmazás.
Minden egyes cikk végén tedd fel
magadnak a kérdést, hogyan tudom
személyesen alkalmazni ezt az elvet az
én helyzetemben? Milyen gyakorlati
lépéseket kell tennem, vagy milyen
változtatásokat kell végrehajtanom ennek
az elvnek az alapján? Ne gondolj
hatalmas dolgokra, egyszerűen csak kezdj
el gyakorolni. A haladásra
összpontosíts, ne a tökéletességre.
Mélyedj el azokban a könyvekben, amelyek
a kezedben vannak. Olvasd őket alaposan.
Merülj el bennük, amíg teljesen
átitatnak. Olvasd újra és újra. Rágd és
emézd meg őket. Engedd, hogy a lényed
részévé váljanak. Tanulmányozz egy jó
könyvet többször. Készíts jegyzeteket és
elemzéseket róla. Egy diák azt fogja
tapasztalni, hogy a szellemét jobban
formálja egy könyv, amelyet alaposan
elsajátított, mint 20 könyv, amelyet
csak felületesen átfutott. Charles
Spurgon. Szervezetünk vezetőinek el kell
köteleződniük az itt leírt
kapcsolatorientált, bátor és szolgálatra
épülő vezetési stílus mellett. Úgy
véljük, embereink vezetésének és
fejlesztésének ez a megközelítése kiemel
minket az üzleti életben, és
elengedhetetlen a maradandó hatás
eléréséhez. Rajtunk múlik, hogy ezeket a
fogalmakat valósággá tegyük a csapataink
számára.
A hivatásként megélt vezetés paradoxona.
Tudjuk, hogy emberként időnként hibázni
fogunk ezeken a területeken. Ezért, bár
teljes elkötelezettséget várunk el,
egymás iránt irgalmasok vagyunk.
Valójában egyikünk sem képes arra, hogy
úgy szeressünk és gondoskodjunk
embereinkről, ahogyan igazán szükséges
lenne. A spirituális vezetés nem egy
olyan hivatás, amit mi választunk. Ez
egy elhívás, amelyre válaszolunk. Nem mi
döntjük el, hogy vezetők leszünk. Mi azt
döntjük el, hogy válaszolunk-e Isten
hívására az életünkben. És Isten nem a
felkészült embereket hívja el, hanem
felkészíti azokat, akiket elhívott. A
Szentírás szerint nincs hatalom, csak
amit Isten alapított, és ez magában
foglalja a te hatalmadat is. Ez azt
jelenti, hogy Isten nevezet ki minket,
függetlenül attól, hogy alkalmasnak
érezzük-e magunkat a feladatra.
Valójában lehet, hogy éppen az
alkalmatlanságunk miatt választott
minket. Nézzétek csak a ti
elhívásotokat, testvéreim. Nem sokan
vannak köztetek, akik emberi megítélés
szerint bölcsek, hatalmasak vagy
előkelők. Sőt, azokat választotta ki
Isten, akik a világ szemében bolondok,
hogy megszégyenítse a bölcseket. És
azokat választotta ki Isten, akik a
világ szemében erőtlenek, hogy
megszégyenítse az erőseket. És azokat
választotta ki Isten, akik a világ
szemében nem előkelők, sőt lenézettek,
és a semmiket, hogy semmikké tegye a
valamiket, hogy egyetlen ember se
dicsekedjék az Isten színe előtt. Első
korintusi levél, első fejezet 26-tól 29.
versig. Ez bátorító.
Isten saját maga választott ki minket a
szerepünkre. Mi hiszünk Istenben, de
Isten is hisz bennünk. Ha Isten vezető
szerepre kent fel minket, fel is fog
készíteni a feladatra, ha kérjük és
folyamatosan elfogadjuk az ő vezetését.
Végül megtapasztaltuk, hogy az a
szívvel, lélekkel végzett vezetési
stílus, amit ebben a könyvben leírtunk,
talán a legnehezebb út. Sas Louis azt
mondta, ha mélyen szeretsz, nagyon fogsz
szenvedni, de mégis megéri. Könnyű lesz?
Nem, megéri.
Abszolút.